stop right there do not buy Apple's
brand new M2 iPad Pro because it is a
marketing trap yes I know their new
video looks awesome the new M2 iPad Pro
looks amazing with all these features
but apple is hiding some things from you
which I'm gonna get into in this video
now yes they've added the new M2 Chip
from their MacBook lineup the hovering
apple pencil feature and more but this
is actually the worst update I've ever
seen on any Apple product in years and
I'm gonna explain why getting right into
it one of the cool new features of the
M2 iPad Pro is that it has a landscape
camera on the side instead of the top
just kidding that's actually the base
budget iPad because the M2 iPad Pro
somehow does not get the new landscape
camera this is actually really stupid
and ridiculous because we had so many
leaks pointing to a new landscape camera
coming to the iPad Pro so as a pro
feature but they give it to the budget
iPad and the brand new M2 iPad Pro does
not get it not only that but Apple gave
us a brand new magic keyboard folio but
only for the base iPad yes the M2 iPad
Pro doesn't get any new keyboard at all
so basically the budget iPad gets all of
the cool new features and accessories
this year while the iPad Pro gets none
of it and you're probably wondering what
exactly did change with the M2 iPad Pro
well I Fondo on Twitter gave us a good
list of basically four changes that's it
just four changes where you're gonna be
going on Amazon and buying a renewed M1
iPad Pro for only
615 dollars absolutely killer deal with
a 90 day Amazon renewed money back
guarantee or instead just 50 bucks off
by the M1 iPad Pro for 750 50 instead of
buying and waiting for the M2 but
getting back to that list we basically
have the M2 Chip the apple pencil hover
feature we have those new prores video
recording features with smart hdr4 and
we have some Wi-Fi differences like
Bluetooth 5.3 and Wi-Fi 6E however there
are some things that apple is hiding
from you within all of those features
that you absolutely need to know about
because most of it is just marketing but
before I explain exactly what I'm
talking about I've got to give a shout
out to the sponsor of this video pulse
way need to troubleshoot while taking
kids of their after school activities
did your server go down at the wrong
place in the wrong time well guess what
pulse way can help with an all-in-one it
management platform that helps you
centrally control all your desktops
servers and network devices even better
their native mobile app gives you
control from anywhere and the best part
they're having a special offer right now
for our viewers click on the link below
start a no commitment trial and become a
true it hero with pulse way now getting
back to the M2 iPad Pro the biggest
issue is that it basically features an
identical display and Camera Hardware
from the 2021 M1 model and this is where
my issue with it comes in because the M1
model came out in April of
2021 which means that it packs camera
Hardware from basically the iPhone 12
lineup of camera Hardware now in Apple's
awesome marketing video they showed off
people using the new M2 iPad Pro as
basically a film camera recording prores
video and then editing it on the iPad
Pro itself however anyone in the real
world is going to be using the best
camera Hardware they can get so why
would they use the new M2 iPad Pro with
old iPhone 12 Hardware where they could
simply grab their iPhone 13 Pro or 14
pro and get much better video quality
since that actually supports Dolby
Vision recording which this M2 iPad Pro
doesn't have so basically anybody that's
serious about video recording would not
be using this iPad Pro with old camera
hardware and now moving on to my next
issue that is the M2 Chip and how apple
is marketing it as a huge deal allowing
creators to do so much more than they
could before with the M1 chip but I
don't believe that well first of all an
Apple's marketing video they showed off
that the M2 Chip is up to 15 faster than
the M1 however when Apple released their
M2 MacBook Air they showed off that it's
18 faster than the M1 which basically
means that Apple has is admitting that
the M2 iPad Pro's chip is hard capped
slower than the same M2 Chip in the
MacBook Air and that's actually the Peak
Performance that's not sustained
performance that might go down even more
due to overheating within the iPad Pro's
smaller chassis in my big issue with all
of that is that the M2 Chip is basically
the only big thing that changed within
this new iPad Pro and apple is making a
huge deal about it however let me show
you guys how powerful the M1 ship
already is because I think it's already
Overkill and you're not going to notice
any real world difference with the M2
Chip just take a look at this gaming
comparison that I did a while back
comparing the tab S8 Ultra to the M1
iPad Pro as you can see in Call of Duty
mobile it was already getting 117 FPS
average with the 120hz display same
thing for Pokemon unite
118.7 average FPS League of Legends wild
Rift
118.1 and then finally the most
graphically intensive game out there for
iOS or iPad OS which is genshin impact
really high performance game
113.8 FPS average which basically means
the M2 Chip isn't really going to do
much for you at all in terms of
noticeable performance improvements at
least for gaming and I believe
everything else as well and now let's
get into the next feature that Apple
showed off in their marketing which is
the new hover feature for the apple
pencil well my issue with that is that
Samsung released hover support for the S
Pen back in
2012. it is nothing new it's nothing
Innovative it's been around for over 10
years and apple is just releasing it
saying that is exclusive to the M2 iPad
Pro where it's really basically just a
software Edition that they added in to
sweeten the deal with the M2 but alright
guys I've got to admit that there is one
really cool change that might actually
be worth it for the M2 iPad Pro which is
the new included woven or braided USBC
cable that is actually nice those cables
are sweet and it's nice that apple is
including it or of course you could just
buy it separately for your M1 iPad Pro
on Apple's website but really the star
of the show is the software once again
because DaVinci Resolve is coming soon
to the iPad Pro enhanced by the M2 Chip
but of course it's not going to be
exclusive to the M2 you could do it on
the M1 or other iPads as well and now if
you're wondering why Apple would do this
to us giving us the worst Apple product
update in years I think I have an
explanation the reason that I see the
iPad Pro not having the landscape camera
or other new hardware changes is because
they are not willing to redesign the
internals or basically anything other
than the chip because it's going to add
to the cost they can simply swap out the
main board with the M2 Chip really quick
and easy but nothing else is being
changed so basically the whole reason
this M2 iPad Pro is getting released is
because it's gonna boost their revenue
at the end of the year and give people
something new to buy so basically Apple
gets to release some new iPads to boost
their profits while using the least
amount of effort with the path of least
resistance and that's probably because
Apple knows that a recession is here or
it's coming so why try very hard and put
out some really nice new products when
sales are probably going to be down
anyway so it's a smart move from Apple
to make an easy and low-cost update to
the iPad Pro and I think it's gonna work
but it's us consumers that are sitting
here disappointed by a really bad M2
iPad Pro update so once again I really
recommend you guys just go and buy the
M1 iPad Pro on Amazon look at that 615
dollars that is a great deal for
everything that you get so with that
said if you completely disagree with my
take in this video then let me know down
in the comment section below but if you
enjoyed it click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and check out Max's video on the new
tension iPad right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
foreign